hey guys it's Alicia Malone with
Fandango movie clips I am near the Welsh
border on the set of the Huntsman the
spin-off film to Snow White and the
Huntsman starring the very handsome mr.
Chris Hemsworth let's go find out more
can you tell me about this location what
it means and what you've been shooting
today this is the the goblin forest
where the the mirror has been stolen and
has been taken in deep into these woods
so we've come here to retrieve it picks
up where the other one left off but we
venture back into the past with my
character and his wife and Ravana
who's jealous that are in the last film
and then her sister played by Emily
Blunt there's a whole sort of backstory
that we discover now you're returning
again playing the same character did she
like the way this idea came about that
it was kind of an original concept seven
from the first one yeah necessarily be
tied in to the first one yeah exists
alongside it must help having Cedric he
just knows what he's doing you know and
because he has a vision where he
believes the eye can be fooled and he's
funny using that does it get as dark as
the first film snow at night I think
it's lighter I've seen that I watched
the first one obviously one night when I
knew I was doing this there's more humor
in this one principally through the
dwarves we're sort of like the
light-hearted aspect of the film and we
bring hopefully we'll make people smile
tell me about dwarf school what exactly
is that it seems like a fun set from
what I've been hearing it's fun yeah
yeah I mean with this is almost done now
we've had four months of I think there's
more bloopers and outtakes in this kind
of people work on what do you love about
this character the Huntsman you know
this episode of a throwback hopefully to
Indiana Jones sort of feel with the film
and this character is kind of just
scraping through with age five somehow
coming out of topple being saved by his
wife
other members of the gang what are you
gonna do take on two evil sisters in
their entire army I pretty much
you